[موسيقى]
لذا فأنت تصمم طائرة كوادكوبتر هو
أنه يخرج منها مباشرة من octocopter
الذي قد يستخدمه مزارع أو أكبر مستجيب أو
حتى مسافر كان
يحلم بالخروج من
ساحة منزلهم أو الخروج من حركة المرور والذهاب إلى
حركة المرور الجماعية و  الذهاب إلى الوجهة
والحلم بعد 100 عام ، ما هو
عرضك الصحيح ، يعتقد الناس أنه
ليس هذا ليس مشروعًا وهميًا إذا
قمت بالتحديق تمامًا ، فهذا يبدو وكأنه
طائرة بدون طيار يدرك الجميع أن الطائرات بدون طيار هي
حالات رائعة جدًا ، إذا
كنا نفعل ذلك  قبل 10 سنوات ، لم
ير أحد حتى ذبابة بدون طيار ، ربما يكون الأمر أكثر
صعوبة إذا كان بإمكانك أن تطير بطائرة بدون طيار ،
يمكنك الطيران هذا هناك زر
يقول لأعلى ولأسفل وهناك عصا تحكم
تقول أنك تعرف المضي قدمًا أو الذهاب إلى
العام الأول هو هذا  سيتم نقلها
من تلقاء نفسها أو هل يمكن أن يكون شخص ما هو
الضوابط ، لذا
سيتم تجريب الإصدار الأول بشكل صحيح ، نحن نبنيها
بشكل مستقل ولكننا نعمل مع
إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية للحصول عليها معتمدة